لان انا مشاهد الان على الشاشه مشاهدينا
هذه الصور التي وصلتنا للتو لاستقبال
الرئيس الصيني في جيم بنك رسميا اذا في
الديوان الملكي السعودي في الرياض اذا
نتابع معكم هذه الصور
الرئيس الصيني شيء بنج كان وصل الى
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض بالامس والان هو
همم يستقبل رسميا اذا في قصر
اليمامه اذا في همم العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض في بهذا الاستقبال بالاعلام
السعوديه والصينيه وبالخيل العربي الاصيل
كمان نتابع اذا في هذه المراسم مراسم
الاستقبال الرسميه للرئيس الصيني همم
الذي يزور المملكه العربيه السعوديه اذا
همم لاول مره منذ 2016 وهي الزياره
الثالثه له التي يجري الى خارج الصين منذ
انتشار وباء كرونه اذا كما نتابع الان صور
الاستقبال الرسمي للرئيس شيجبنك في
في الديوان الملكي بالرياض قبل قليل
اذا
كما تبعنا المتابع اذا في استقباله ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
اذا الرئيس الصيني شيء جيمنج اذا يستقبل
من قبل
الامير محمد بن سلمان في الديوان الملكي
بالرياض في اا مستهل هذه الزياره
مع ترقب انطلاق اذن القمه السعوديه همم
الصينيه اليوم تليها غدا قمه عربيه صينيه
وكذلك خليجيه صينيه بمشاركه عدد من القاده
والزعماء همم العرب
خد
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور قبل قليل
نستمع الى السلام الوطني
[موسيقى]
همم